foreign
basically he doesn't miss home loves the
freedom and realizes that he's really
been watering himself down and
conforming into our routine which I get
you know we have three kids it's hectic
yeah but it's his routine too I mean
that
[Music]
what is going on this is John with the
Dr John deloney's show
I mean literally the greatest mental
health and marriage and parenting
podcasts and Pet Care podcast and
roadway cleaning podcast that has ever
existed and I'm just going to keep
adding things because we're making this
whole thing up anyway I'm so glad you're
with us talking about your marriage
what's going on in your heart and your
mind in your head in your family
whatever you got going on
um I'm here for it if you want to be on
the show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask a s k
um if you've got some success stories
please continue to send those in um
Jenna and Kelly are getting them and
they're amazing And for those of you who
write me letters
it's just truly
um such an honor and a gift and I'm
grateful for you thank you so so much
for doing that
um and don't forget building a
non-anxious life still up for pre-sale
if you're on the fence about us 20 bucks
you're gonna spend that much on coffee
this week and if you're like no I'm not
yeah you are so
um just take a week off and pick up this
book and I'm I'm confident it's a game
changer for folks go to John deloney.com
and check check it out let's run out to
one of my favorite places on planet
Earth New Orleans Louisiana and talk to
Dear Marie what's up Marie
so Dr John how are you partying what are
you up to
nothing just hanging in there
excellent what's up how can I help
yeah so um I have a question and I'm
just going to give you a quick little
rundown so my husband and I recently
celebrated our two-year anniversary and
we knew that he had a work trip a work
trip coming up for about five weeks so
anyway he's been on that trip for two
weeks the first week communication just
was not there not really talking to me
and I told him how important you know
hearing from him was especially while
I'm at home with the kids
and um so finally we talked almost at
that week Mark and he has just come to
this realization that life is so good
you know just not having any anxiety any
worries and
um just all of these doubts in his head
now about our relationship and our
marriage and I'm just I'm not sure how
to move forward with it and and what
else to do on my end
okay let me let me see let me see if I
can piece on this together so y'all been
together for two years and you've got
you've got multiple kids or those from
another relationship
yes okay and how old are your kids
have a four-year-old which um
eight-year-old and a 13 year old okay
all right and so y'all got married and
how how old are you and how old is he
I am 31 he's 33. okay
so y'all get married he goes on a trip
and that peace and quiet
like so I I've got two kids and when I
travel my wife travels I'm I'm flying
out um tonight so I'll fly out
um and there will be about 12 hours when
it's it's incredible
and it's so quiet and like I can make
snow angels on the bed and there's
nobody like Hey Dad hey Dad hey Dad can
I have a snack like none of that exists
for 12 hours it's awesome yeah and then
by about hour 13 I hate my life I can't
wait to get back okay and sometimes
that's 24 hours 48 hours
um my wife can go two or three days but
she wears more of it during the week
right so what you're saying is he went
away and didn't call you didn't talk to
you didn't reach out yeah yeah no and I
was just you know I'm at home with
um so we have my two kids full time and
I'm at home with them you know the
little ones wanting to talk to Daddy and
you know no no calls nothing and and I'm
missing him you know I'm like I miss my
husband I missed him around here I miss
having that adult interaction and he
just he didn't want to take that time to
call you know he's he's got buddies I
get it like enjoy your time while you're
out there but um I'm like hey don't
forget that we're here and so finally I
was like hey we haven't talked in a week
can we talk and on that phone call
um he said basically he doesn't miss
home that he just loves the freedom and
realizes that he's really been watering
himself down and conforming into our
routine which I get you know we have
three kids it's hectic it's crazy we've
got schedules and yeah but it's his
routine too I mean yeah
okay first I'm just gonna be as honest
as possible to you and I'm gonna tell
you
there's not really a road map here like
in the scientific literature I'm just
gonna tell you what I would do okay
um I would be stunned and I've been
stunned before on the show I've been
wrong often on the show before I would
be very surprised if there's not
somebody else
well you know since you mentioned that
you know it's crazy how God works like
always so
um on Instagram just scrolling looking
and a picture came up and I was like oh
you know oh cool it's him like a work
function so um I clicked on it to look
and it was posted by a female and I
guess because he liked the picture it
had popped up on a suggested I don't
even know but um I looked at it and I
found out that you know the times that
he did talk to me and tell me he was
going to eat with the guys that they
hadn't hung out with any girls that that
had been false and there was this one
particular girl he had been hanging out
with on a regular occasion just you know
leaving it out and um I'm not just
leaving it out
like he's lying to your face right yeah
and and I told him that I was like Hey
like I don't understand how you can feel
comfortable like lying to the person
you're married with like that's a big
deal to me and it makes me feel
extremely insecure like knowing that
you're lying and basically he said that
he did not want to get lectured or
questioned and he's old enough he knows
how to handle himself
here's what I think's happening here's
another thing's happening I think
um he is with somebody right now
and what he's doing because he's a
coward and a child is he's gonna make
this this disintegration of your
relationship your fault
I don't like conforming you're squashing
me you're judging me you're leaning on
me you're doing these things to me and
look what happened I just had to go fill
in the blank I had to go for a week and
not talk to you so this is um I'm gonna
give you like some secret Guy Code stuff
that you're not supposed to know because
you're not in the gang right but I'm
gonna tell you if I go like on a guy's
trip we all go to Vegas we all go watch
the fights we all go do a thing right
we all go on a hunting trip on a fishing
trip whatever there is always always a
moment when everybody splits up and
calls home
always
yeah I I can't wrap my head I can't
think I'm trying to think I can't think
of a time in the last 20 years that that
hasn't happened
and if it doesn't it's a very clear like
hey I'm gonna be in the woods tomorrow
and I won't be able to call out
I'll love you and as soon as I get
signal I'll reach out
but like so this idea like I was with
the Bros we all forgot that's stupid
because even all I guarantee you some of
those guys broke out and said hey I
gotta go call home and it's uh it's not
uncommon for everyone to be like I gotta
go call home but
most of the time guys can't wait to call
home and check in
yeah right and so you're not crazy yeah
and this I'm just going to talk to you
for a week is madness that's nuts it's
just nuts and
um it's a very cowardly exchange so I'm
gonna tell you what I would do
and this is a terrible recommendation
and so I can't recommend it to you what
I'm telling you is this is what I would
do
it's my wife
was gone and she was going on a two how
long is this work trip by the way
um it's almost five weeks and so we're
what does he do like
uh he is it's military training
well that kind of changes things is
there a possibility he doesn't have
access to his phone
does
um he does he's just made it clear that
like he's really enjoying his you know
life and I get it the first two years of
our marriage had been you know it's been
hard we've been having to figure out how
we can
um blend our families together we're
figuring out communication which has
been you know a really hard spot for us
yeah but you don't quit you don't quit
yeah no and you know for the last two
weeks I've been reminding him that I'm
like hey I'm here for you I love you um
you know let um I want to work on things
I want to fix things because he didn't
say anything about this before he left
he's like oh a relationship is great no
it's because he's a coward what what
does he tell you what does he tell you
when you say I love you and I don't want
to work on this
Vibes are like when he gets home
dude you're not still trying out this
isn't a tryout
I know and like I'm it makes me feel
crazy because I'm like am I crazy for me
no no you're not crazy anymore no
and yeah if he was to come in and say or
before he left listen the last two years
have wrecked me in a way I didn't
anticipate
and
um
I'm I need a couple of weeks of no
communication because I got some hard
things to sort out in my mind
yeah and that would be a truly
devastating conversation to have in
person
and it's basically like a we're going to
take a quick like a quick two-week
three-week separation we're gonna take a
quick two or three like this me going
away for five weeks is bigger than
just um we're gonna be a part like I
I've got to get my head screwed on
straight and I got to figure out if this
is what I want for the rest of my life
and like if that was a friend of mine I
would challenge the premise of that just
because it doesn't align with my
personal values
but that's the respectable way to do
something like that right
it's not just a ghost the your wife
so no you're not crazy
at all
um to answer like I would get in a in a
car or I would fly out and I would meet
that person directly
yeah and I don't know if that's possible
on a military base I don't know if
there's if there's evening release I
don't know any any of the details around
that
but I would have to know you're not
going to just not talk you're not going
to just ghost me if you are leaving me
we're gonna have this conversation now
because you mean that much to me and my
marriage means that much to me I also
know this that is not a safe situation
for everybody it's not a smart situation
for most and so I can't recommend it
what I'm saying is
it would mean that much to me that
everything in my life stops right this
second
right in a second and that becomes
number one priority
yeah and I you know I felt I felt that
way you know I thought about it but I'm
like just the responses that I'm getting
from him like I I think he might be
upset you know if I went over there and
it's so I've been I've been trying to
give him a mistake yeah yeah hold on
hold on why do you think so little of
you Marie
like I don't want him to be upset how's
his wife supposed to feel she's getting
left via text message
like I mean and he's just gonna check
out The Vibes when he gets back I mean
come on
yeah it's just you deserve more than a
person you deserve more than this
yeah and the way you're interacting with
the way you're talking the way and as I
say like I'm almost I'd be willing I I
just I'm fairly certain there's somebody
else involved
and if there is he needs to have the
courage to sit down face to face with
you and say I've fallen for somebody
else or I am cheating on you right now
or I got married I met somebody else and
I haven't been totally honest with you
and I know that I've broken your heart
and devastated you and the lives of
these kids but this is our reality right
now
that is the noble way to handle a very
unknowable situation I don't even think
a Noble's a word
but that's how you do that
and he's not and he's leaving you the
wife
dangling on the end of this line
wondering what you did
and I hate it for you I'm sorry you're
not crazy
well you have to ask yourself here's the
here's the the metric you have to ask
yourself what does this relationship
mean to you
what does
um
the marriage mean to you what does this
person mean to you and
you gotta own reality too
if you think this person's if he's been
lying to you forever and gets mad at you
for calling him on him if you think he's
been cheating on you and gets mad at you
you don't get to be my parent I'm your
wife
and you start to go oh oh you start to
like almost like watching The Sixth
Sense and they they replay those those
key scenes and you're like oh I missed
it if that's you right now then you've
got some harder conversations to have
some direct conversations but here's the
the bigger picture I want you to take
your autonomy and power back in this
relationship
because it's a hundred percent one-sided
as though he's been doing you a favor
by checking out the vibe and you're
passing the vibe test so he hangs and
then once he's out he's like I don't
like the Vibes we're gonna chill here
as though you're like a surfing spot
you deserve more you deserve more
and if he wants to call or show I'd love
to talk to him man I'd love to talk to
him
frustrating to hear this side of it
this is this is the John Delaney show
we'll be right back
[Music]
this episode is sponsored by betterhelp
hey this is deloney I hope you all are
doing well listen sometimes it's hard to
get our brains to turn off and I know
what I'm talking about I am the king of
racing thoughts they've kept me up at
night they've got me up early and kept
me from connecting with people I love if
you find your thoughts start to race
right before bed or during other super
inconvenient times a great way to make
those racing thoughts slow down or stop
is to talk them through and therapy gave
me a place to do that so I could get off
the negative thought treadmill learn
positive coping skills set healthy
boundaries and find some mental and
emotional peace and it can help you too
if you're thinking of starting therapy
give better help a try better help is
convenient because it's entirely online
so it's flexible and can fit into your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and you can even
switch therapists at any time for no
extra charge so take a break from racing
Thoughts with better help visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we're back let's go out to Gin
in Omaha Nebraska what's up Jen
oh my gosh Dr John I cannot believe I'm
talking to you I you know I was just
thinking I cannot believe I'm talking to
Jen from Omaha hey what what is like um
uh what's like the thing to do in Omaha
um well like I know Bright Eyes is from
there like a songwriter that I love but
other than oh that I don't know anything
about Omaha what's like the thing to do
in Omaha
well the College World Series is always
pretty popular yeah I need to go to that
that's on my bucket list and thanks
Omaha Steaks are from there
yes awesome they're delicious
they're delicious anyone that doesn't
understand Nebraska it really is
beautiful you just got to get off the
interstate oh it's stunning I've been
there yeah it's these beautiful Hills
that just go on for eternity it's it's
it's it's incredible yeah I love it I
love it all right so what's up how can I
help I want a geography podcast so bad
but they won't let me have one all right
so what's up
so
I um
I have just been battling with this
question for quite a while and I just
can't seem to find an answer but my
question is how do you find your
identity again after being a cheater
tell me more
so I don't even know where to start
honestly
um
I've
so my husband and I we've been together
10 years married for four and
um
we always kind of had
little issues in our relationship prior
to being engaged and married and my best
like description of that was the Red
Flags never caused me to raise the White
Flag so we just kind of moved through it
and you know took everything in stride
and
then
um we went through like a really
stressful time in our life we were we
were engaged planning our wedding we
decided to both go back to school
because we wanted to further our careers
that was during covid and
um after we got married I got pregnant
so we were and I was working in
healthcare it was just a whole lot of
stress all in one and when I when we
came out on the other side
I had a different career a different
place and I got out of healthcare
and I um
met a guy through my new career and I
connected with him on an emotional level
that out stepped outside the boundaries
of my marriage and you know it's been
about
a year and a half now
and we've
um
we just separated and
you know it's just a lot you you and
your husband or you and him okay no um
me and my husband just separated okay
um did you sleep with this guy
no okay
so
you met somebody had a crush on him
after his particularly chaotic time
um
you violated it like you violated your
own conscience here right
there had to be there had to be more of
a reason why y'all separated
um well that was
mostly from things that were going on in
our own relationship but a lot of it
I think he really blames
the cheating but
I have I mean we've we've been in
therapy for like over a year now and
um I've I've even listened to parts of
your podcast that you know kind of give
um direction or maybe some guidance as
to like how we could work through these
things and I feel like we
were
I don't know if I should say we but I
feel like I kind of tried to
reconcile what had gone on and he didn't
want to and he told me that yeah I bowed
out and now he wants to wonder why we're
separating and
that's right so
I just feel like I can't ever
you know like I I held myself to such a
standard in my life that I was a I'm a
good person and I have morals and I have
no I think what you did was I think you
I think you tethered your values to a
series of things you won't do
and if we tether our values to a series
of things I don't do I don't drink I
don't smoke I don't have sex I don't
ever
have a crush or fall deeply
um for somebody that I'm not married to
I don't sleep with somebody I'm not
married to what fill in the blank
I don't steal
if you anchor your values into a series
of actions you don't take
and you stumble into or walk into or do
one of those actions your entire
um identity your entire picture of
yourself Burns to the ground
and you so you anchored into not I'm
somebody who is always growing I'm
somebody I want to be the best wife
possible
then you
have an emotional affair with somebody
and you
um
uh
sit down have a hard conversation and
You Weep and you grieve and you mourn
what was and you'll build something new
and then you continue to try to be the
best wife you can be
because you weren't in that moment it
wasn't a or in that season it was not a
uh it's not an a picture that is stamped
into concrete this is who you are
it was a bad bad season but when you
anchor into I will not do this thing and
then you do that thing there's nowhere
to go
and just for what it's worth
working through this I think is
um one thousand percent possible
you nailed it and I think that's what
you're struggling with he doesn't want
to I think it was a lot of the other
stuff that went on in our relationship
that
I I just
I just could not get my like I could not
wrap my head around doing those things
or being that person tell me about it
which ones tell me let's don't be vague
let's be real Direct
hold on hold on for somebody to call
like the way you ask the question let's
just start here and just get all the
cards out on the table face up like how
do I how do I find my identity after
being a cheater
the way you asked that I thought you
were going to tell me that you cheated
on a high school boyfriend you cheated
on three College boyfriends and you
slept with three or four guys since
you've been married
this is if I'm not wrong
you met somebody you fell for them you
probably had some conversations you
shouldn't have had you were hiding your
cell phone from them maybe sent pictures
you shouldn't have like
tell me what I'm missing here because
you're you're you're the label and
identity you've given to yourself is not
what I would have given you
hit the nail on the head
I just don't
don't if me and my husband don't work
things out which honestly I I the way
that things are going I don't see us
getting back together but partially with
the separation was for us to
to step back from the relationship that
we've been in and the problems we've
been having and and all of this and to
decide
is is
moving forward together something that
we want to do and we want to work on or
are we going to move forward apart and
you know pull on divorce and
separate everything and I think um
it's it's it's only been a month that
we've been separated and you know the
other day he he was like I don't want to
drag this out anymore and I was like
it's been four weeks what are we
dragging out like
he may have been divorced for a year
he just didn't have the courage to say
it
because he didn't want to see himself as
a guy who got who his wife had a crush
on somebody else
what else happened at home
so I think the
big
turning point was
um
like about two and a half years ago
when
I think like there's never been much of
like me wanting to do things with him
like physically and his
he is such a physical connector that
you know for for years I just would
kind of push under the rug and and I
would just think that I thought
something was wrong with me that I
didn't feel like I wanted to have sex
with him or like do things with him and
I mean I asked like my doctor and I
tried downloading apps and I tried to
like make myself want it and I just
didn't and and don't and I think the big
Turning Point a few years ago was
um we got into an argument and
our relationship had always been pretty
good I actually always thought that we
had a stellar relationship above a lot
of other people and
I think I hung on to that Vision until
we got in this argument about I don't
remember what it started with but he
said that he was unwanted and unloved
and
he said
is
like just says life wasn't worth living
anymore and he left
and he told me youth not coming back
and I just
could not bear the thought that my child
would lose her father
and
I just I called him and I I tried to
talk him back and and
can I hop in here real quick yeah that
answer you just gave is very instructive
for me
and maybe it's not the full picture I
don't want to hold you to it
but if your husband looks at you and
said I've felt unloved
for long enough
and your first thought is I don't want
to lose my best friend I Don't Want to
Lose the person who I love more than
anything on the planet
this search for me figuring out ways
that I can love you in the ways that you
need to be loved or you want to be loved
will never cease because I love you to
the end of the Moon and back
that's one thing
that your first thought went to I don't
want my daughter to lose her dad
it gets worse okay keep going
I talked him back
and he came back home and
said I mean he I had never seen him in
the state I mean at this point we'd been
together for like eight years and this
is the first time I'd ever seen him cry
and it was just a manic
date that I didn't know what to do and
when he came back home he said you need
to give me physical affection and I said
I want to and I try but I just I just
don't feel it and and he's like well
then I'm just gonna leave again and I'm
I'm not coming back and so I
like
I just made myself
do what he wanted and
you know after it was done
he just
he didn't seem to to care that
he essentially was like
making me do something that I didn't
want to do after he just told me
that he was gonna leave and go kill
himself and
the that behavior didn't change
for
about two years
so every time we would get in some sort
of argument or something would happen he
would storm off and leave and threaten
things and if I didn't
bow down to the physical
intimacy then
um
I just I just could not hold on you're
describing two different things
there's a difference between a sexless
marriage there's difference between what
is so gross about me that you won't hold
my hand you won't put your hand on my
shoulder those are super common
conversations that anybody who works
with couples has on a daily basis
what you're describing is abuse
you will do this particular sex act with
me or I'm going to kill myself
well that's like how the cycle went for
so long I know but listen to me listen
to me that is not love and affection
that is abuse that is taking advantage
of somebody
that is not what that is
and you can be very loving and very
affectionate
and say one this sex act isn't for me
I'm not into it
and of all my like what I would call my
ride or die is like my long-term friends
and family every one of those couples
and we're super close but we've been
closed since we're back in college
um sometimes in high school
everyone's everyone's like I'm not into
that I'm super into that it's all
different it's all different
but it's it's a conversation between a
couple right so hear me say you're not
crazy it just boiled down to I couldn't
say no
hold on you well I don't say I I being
in those kind of situations is is a mess
and that's not for me to judge from here
um
so on let's back all the way out and get
back to the original question because
let me say this
your
um I think this relationship needs
infinitely more work than you think it
does
oh yeah okay
and if you were to call me and just have
told me what you said without you like
having a crush on us on a co-worker if
what you had just if you just called and
said my husband says either I do this
particular sex act or he says he's going
to kill himself in storms out of the
house I would tell you to run
and if you've listened to this show very
long you know I don't tell people that
but that's a that's a
manipulative degrading way to
get what you want
and has no place inside of a marriage
I think where
where despite everything that went on
and I still did that I just feel like I
can't trust myself like am I even worthy
of being committed to to another person
absolutely ever again in my life like
can I call myself a good person yes ever
again in my life I will I'll call you a
good person right now
I just don't feel like as someone who
did that like I just can't
I just I just don't feel like I am like
worthy of being in a relationship
or worthy of being considered a good
person who has any sort of moral or
value in their life I think you anchored
into
good people do this and good people
don't do that
good people stay married forever
good wives make their husbands
um so happy they just can't leave
anywhere else
bad wives husbands leave them bad wives
do X Y or Z bad wife say no this hurts
bad wives say this makes me feel
uncomfortable so I'm not gonna do any of
that
which what you're saying is good wives
bury themselves in the yard
and become walkways for their husbands
bad wives say no have boundaries Etc
did you do something that was dumb yeah
100 percent
or I'll even I'll even back out of that
did you do something that violated one
of your core values yeah you did
you got to make peace with yourself yeah
in the future
if you're with somebody and you're in a
committed relationship and somebody at
work is hilarious or good looking or
they make you feel alive or they put
their hand in the smaller back and let
tell you to go out of the elevator first
and it just sends a jolt of electricity
through does that happen yeah and now
you know I'm not going to respond to
those tags
or I just don't respond to texts
or I don't I'm not gonna answer those
emails or fill in the blank you see what
I'm saying like you've learned
it's not good on those roads anymore
yeah the ultimate question is
is Jen going to be able to get to a
place where Jen honors and loves Jen
again
and what I want to tell you is
sounds like for the last few years and
that like there's no way this just
popped up after eight years
there has been some sort of they call it
in the the one down position so it like
in counseling there's the one-up
position there's the guys that beat
their chest and scream and yell are the
wives who scream and yell and beat their
chest whatever then there's the one down
position usually it's well you guys just
go eat whatever you want I'll just be
hungry that's fine and everyone's like
all right where do you want to go eat
right so it's a very
like okay well just whatever I'll just
I'll just sleep on the couch then if if
you need those sheets on the bed it's
that right that's that's a power move I
would be willing to bet money that that
has been part of The Narrative of your
marriage that just erupted into a
you do this or I'm killing myself
and so often when somebody's been in a
relationship for so long that's full of
chaos that's full of uh ups and downs
and is being dragged around underwater
by someone who's manipulative
to the point of the abuse you've
suffered you you get disconnected from
yourself
and you try to find reasons to justify
why this insane evil behavior is
happening to you
and then I have a conversation like this
that breaks my heart
because sometimes it's
well did you gain 10 pounds yes are you
the grossest no stop
did this happen yes did you forget his
keys yes
did you fall for somebody at work and
not sleep with them yes that happened
but for some reason you've bought into
that narrative that you're the worst
person who's ever lived actually Jeremy
say you're not
I personally think the separation is
really good
and after four weeks if he wants to bail
then I think
um his behavior is a language and he's
giving you all the information you need
you're gonna have to grieve the loss of
your marriage
but this marriage is not going to end
because
you had a crush on a co-worker period
do you believe me when I say that
I feel like it's something that I want
to believe but it's it's so hard to I
know
it's the truth
my
if you haven't already I think it's
important for you to get with a
counselor on your own and I want you to
speak out loud exactly what you've told
me
and my guess is you have not told that
story
especially not to a mental health
professional because every alarm they
have would have gone off like mine is
right now
I'm so so so so so sorry
but no
you're not a terrible person yes you're
worthy of being loved yes you're worthy
of being loved forever
yes this is your relationship
um may not stand this test it's over
maybe not but it sounds like it and if
y'all choose to stay together there's
gonna have to be some
drastic changes in both you and
especially your husband's way of
interacting with the world
and he's gonna have to take a knee in
front of his wife and say I've abused
you for years and that stops now
you're worth more than this gin we'll be
right back
all right we're back let's go out to
stock ton California home of the Diaz
brothers and talk to Alex what's up Alex
hi John how are you doing good how are
you
um hopefully better after this call oh
there's been two tough ones so give me
an easy one
uh in that case that I
can all right I'm here with you let's do
it what's up
okay so let me start by the question
um is there anything else I can do to
help or stop my 12 year old daughter
from getting bullied oh man that's cool
yeah
yeah all right so
as you can imagine I've dealt with this
situation for my whole career so I'm
gonna go all the way to the back and I'm
gonna ask you a few questions they're
gonna sound hard is that okay
yeah okay
well actually before I do that explain
to me teach me about the bowling what's
going on
has been going through a lot of bullying
a group of friends and um
they I've constantly been called I've
went there I've huffed and puffed and
demanded to talk to the bully's parents
and it is impossible
I can't even set up a meeting with the
parents I can't even leave my phone
number to the parents it's like they cut
off complete communication or any kind
of like negotiation
I I feel like the school is just
I'm mad I'm sad I'm just like a mix of
emotions
well
I uh I'm gonna do something I really
don't do but I understand the school's
position on this one usually I'm
complaining about the schools
I would I'm glad that kids can't come to
school and demand con my contact
information and call me
I think that's I think that's unwise you
see you know what I'm saying I get that
but I also get that you want you want
Justice and tell me what's what they're
doing to your daughter
uh they're constantly calling their
names and um every time that I go and
complain to the office it's like
she they start calling her a snitch and
um so she stops telling me
but I can tell she's still going through
it
and what's the school's response
do this first let's do this first and
then it's been three years Sean like
where is gonna be the final the the
finale where are we gonna get to the
actual response to it
I mean they put her in so many programs
like it just feels like they're more
into trying to make the changes on her
than the actual bullies that might not
be what's happening close doors but
that's how I feel
that's actually been the move okay and
there was
um so bullying is complex right so just
for everybody listening
um bullying is repeated harm it can be
harassment too but it's repeated and it
often
um has a almost I think by definition
has a power hierarchy to it okay so
um
it's the kid who's not the athletic one
and the other Athletics kids are on to
them or they're the not so pretty
because they're going through an awkward
phase and the kids are mean or they've
got braces so there's a there's a
hierarchy there's a power Dynamic there
um
and for years there was a bunch of
conversations about how to deal with the
bully
and a friend of mine named Steve is a
counseling Guru said he was concerned
about this 20 years ago
caused we had stopped teaching kids how
to deal with bullies
and we had just focused fully on a fully
on on the bad guys whoever the bad guys
happen to be and we have to remember bad
guys are kids right so I do expect the
school to come in and say you will not
say those things
and I also expect parents in somewhat
schools to begin to react to or teach
the person who's on the receiving end
especially in what I would call
non-physical violence right you're not
going to die or get put in hospital if
you don't deal with this stuff
um they've got to deal with
they've got to learn those skills
because this is going to be people are
mean right you deal with this out in the
real world right I'll tell you so
um
here's a hard question
what are the things they are saying and
I ask this because there's different
levels of sensitivity and I know I'm
gonna get in trouble on the internet and
that's fine what I'm wondering is this
is the school looking at this situation
and seeing a group of friends
um saying
nice I'm just gonna say what my friend
said
nice face deloney
they used to call me zitcom because I
had bad acne as a kid sitcom they said
all the time
but these are like my best friends in
the world
and it was mean it hurt my feelings but
also I said my things back and we like
that it was just so I wouldn't have been
classified as bullying right
yeah
um and so sometimes there are since
there's kids whose sensitivity alarms is
is more finely tuned and there are
sometimes parents who if their kid comes
home they said something mean just blow
the roof off of everything I'm calling
everybody so
like just as an objective third-party
Outsider I've got a 13 year old myself
what do I saying to your daughter
are they not including her are they
being mean you know they just saying hey
we don't want you to come to our
sleepover party and that's the bullying
you're talking about like what are we
talking about here
they actually call her names
um I'm not gonna say which names but
they're really insulting about her looks
like you just mentioned
um
and um I've I've explained it to her the
difference between bullying and being a
jerk okay you know and and I I do tell
her like you have to understand there's
some people that have a personality that
you know they're just not happy all the
time and then you have the other people
that are just like picking at you like
poking the bear you know and that's what
she's telling me is happening
mm-hmm
so there's a bully researcher by the
name of Izzy I think it's comlin Camlin
Coleman Izzy Coleman that's what Izzy
Coleman
and
he talks about one of the corners like
one of the keys of poking the bear is
a bear that is unable to be poked
so I know you've had that conversation
with her when one of these kids says
something about her appearance and by
the way these aren't her friends like I
wouldn't even refer to them as your
friends at school
they clearly are not
if she's been if she's been like hey
that's not funny I don't like that
and they're like nah we do we're gonna
keep doing it
um exactly
then they're not her friends right
um
what is what's the response when you
walk her through like hey you know what
if somebody says something walk away
like they're looking for the response
we're not going to give them a response
because clearly if they're saying
something that ugly there's something
going on in their heart and mind in
their house
so she said that at first she did walk
away like she did walk away but it just
seemed like it wasn't it didn't stop and
I have actually went through bullying
myself and the same thing happened to me
you know I don't feel like walking away
actually helps it it just makes it more
easier for them because they don't get
in trouble for it because all you're
doing is walking away
except that when you accept that when
you tell
it they they double up right not only do
you have braces or not only are you flat
chested or not only do not have the
right hair now you're a snitch too
yeah exactly
so Izzy uh Dr Kellman has a technique
where he will as somebody says
um oh my gosh you're so fat right and
and the response is
you're the most beautiful kid in school
or oh my gosh you're such a slow Runner
well you're the fastest runner out here
and that there's a counterweight that is
so significant to that
and the response is often a one-word
resp like yeah
or huh
now that might be an after school
special response but when I read it it
sounded at least like huh
it's just like I'm not it's so I'm not
playing that game now does that take the
sting out of what they said no
I just I've as an educator I found it
harder and harder to legislate that
like because kids are going to say
things to kids they're gonna post things
about kids they're going to write things
in little notes and I get that we want
to stop that if we see it we're gonna
call it out we're gonna bring kids in
and say hey
it's devastating to talk about
somebody's physical appearance don't do
that don't do that
and if I hear about it again you're
going to be in detention
but that's hard right
so I was going to say if even if she did
do that it's going to be a little bit
difficult for her because she's going
through a lot of depression anxiety and
for her to be like positive response
back when she just feels completely down
um that's difficult for her because I've
tried to tell her something like that
and well I totally get it I totally get
it but here's what I want to say you'll
have to choose your heart here
continuing for three years on a track
that's not working
absent take your kid out of school and
that sounds like you just get a kid out
of there well if you're a working parent
in a like in a community that's not
always that easy right
um and just I can't just quit working
homeschool you because we got bills to
pay so I there's there's a there's
there's a trapped element here right
um she's gonna have to choose her hard
what I think y'all should spend some
time doing instead of just telling her
you need to you need to
you'll have to role play this thing
you're gonna have to practice and
practice and practice and practice
almost to the point that it becomes
silly here's how that looks in my house
okay and this is something that I've
been practicing for years is this the
right way to do this I don't think so
but it's a way and it worked for me as a
kid
if I say
gosh it stinks in here
my son will just automatically without
even looking up go you stink
and without even blinking my daughter
will just respond your face stinks
here's what I'm trying to teach them and
I've been teaching this for years in my
house number one
um there's a time and a place
and if there's other adults if I'm being
serious that behavior doesn't happen
but I don't want words from other kids
to have quite the sting
and so we've turned that into a game
yeah their bodies are not going to
respond as though it's a threat now if
they're in love with somebody if this is
their Core group of people different
ball game
but if the instant response is oh I've
played basketball I've got another shot
then then it changes the dynamic okay
that's not for every family and that's
definitely not for every kid so I can't
recommend that but a practice of
um
your shoes are ridiculous those are the
cheap issues well you have the nice
issues it's less about being super
positive and what we're doing is we're
just teaching a different karate kick
right but it's one that's not going to
get anybody in trouble it's just gonna
stop the behavior because here's what we
know
walking away as you said isn't super
helpful
telling on them isn't super helpful
right what are the things you've tried
trying to get in touch with their
parents not super helpful
right so uh
can I tell you this one time though that
it actually I felt like a win yeah go
for it um so there was this one time
after I picked up my daughter after
school
and we were driving back home and we see
one of the bullies going into their
house
so I saw where the bully lived and um
and I told my daughter I said tell that
bully that if he doesn't stop we know
where he lives and I'm gonna go talk to
his mom
and the bully my goodness his response
was like I don't give a f
so I was like oh okay he doesn't care no
problem so I go and knock on the door
talk to the mom and the mom acts like
she is so surprised it's the first time
her hearing it even though the school
said that they called her a million
times right
so then I it still happened after that
went back a second time
and I end up telling her listen this has
been going on and this was back a few
months ago so it was like two years I
was like this has been going on for two
years I'm tired of it I'm at my wit's
end
and I'm telling you I I'm gonna put a
juvenile restraining order on your child
on behalf of my daughter which means
that you would have to transfer to a
different school and probably move
because we live really close by
and I don't want to do that that's the
last thing that I want to do
and you're not going to believe it John
that bully stopped completely oh I don't
doubt it for a second yeah I'm done for
a second
um
why haven't you done that to all those
kids why don't you put a restraining
order on them
yeah I and you know what and I've tried
to call the police too by the way
they've been called like twice the first
time it was because my daughter wanted
to um
and her life and she said it in school
and they called the police and they
suggested me to take her to the crisis
center
and um
the second time was me calling them
about this bullying thing and it just
seems like the police is more on how the
school is handling it yeah yeah is there
an option is there an option to take her
out of this situation just get her out
of the mess
yeah but you know I feel like
transferring is not going to do anything
the bullies are still going to bully if
it's not my daughter is going to be
someone else I understand that but right
now let's take care of your daughter
like you're right there's a longer game
to play here but every day this thing
goes on your daughters is is at the in
the middle of it
yeah and at least it gives a control alt
delete for your daughter because she's
gonna have to learn some skills
yeah we cannot have a culture where
everybody is walking around because it
just because that window gets narrower
narrower and narrower and narrower right
yeah and so she's gonna have to what I
mean by that the window gets narrower
from what hurts my feelings and what I
consider bullying versus what you
consider bullying and it and then all of
a sudden none of us can move
yeah and then the only move is start
canceling people right that's been our
culture the last five or six years
gonna have to learn some skills on
standing up for herself on not accepting
this on walking away on appropriately
challenging back
um Etc
and that will help with as she learns
gains confidence in those responses that
will help her entire psyche
and you're watching your daughter
shrivel up in front of you over the last
three years get her out of this
environment man if you can get her out
you're right and then we'll play the
long game fair
I don't want you to look at this like
you lost I want you to look at this like
you saved your daughter's life
okay
you're right
because I feel like you're going to war
with a bunch of 13 year olds and 12 year
olds
and I feel like you're gone to war with
12 year olds and parents that you've
never met and may never meet
and you're going to war against a school
that isn't doing enough to protect your
daughter and you're going to war against
a young girl's mental health challenges
that are continued dwindle in front of
you what I'm gonna tell you is quit
going to war
foreign
get your daughter out of this mess take
her to a safe place
and then you can begin teaching her some
skills then y'all can practice at home
not in the car on the way to work like
all right so if anyone says anything
you're just gonna say no no no we're
just gonna role play at home
now you know shoes are stupid oh you've
got great shoes
you can't even run right is that fun
when you say that yeah hmm
we're just gonna practice those things
and it may not pay off when she's 13 it
may not pay off she's 14 but when she's
19 in college and somebody says
something like that then she's going to
have a skill set that many 19 year olds
don't have
and so everybody listening to this
um
this bullying stuff is such a disaster
it's such a mess because it's so clear
that it destroys kids and it's also so
clear that it's kids doing it's kids
trying to be funny or kids trying to not
feel less than and it's hard to
legislate that it's very hard
because you can Outlaw saying mean
things but that's going to be subjective
across the board and you can Outlaw
um if you say this one more time to this
kid you are out of here which I think
should have happened in this case and
the school has chosen not to do that for
whatever reason
I'm going to double down if I can if any
possibility and get my kid out of there
I'm also going to double down and try to
teach my kid some skills and if I don't
have those skills we're going to give
with a child counselor we're going to
figure these skills out work with the
school counselor at this new school
banging my head for three years because
the whole time I'm banging my head my
kid is going to school there every day
every day there every day
and parents if you have a kid who's a
jerk
stop it stop it it's not funny it's
funny when my seven-year-old makes a
joke at my expense that's funny but
we're all in it together
but you'll never hear my daughter do
that to somebody else because she's too
sensitive
she cares too much about other people
raise kids who care about other people
[Music]
bullying starts and stops in the house
often
stop
[Music]
because there's another little kid on
the other side of this that's trapped
[Music]
right back
hey what's up Dr John deloney here check
it out my new book building a
non-anxious life is now available for
pre-order here's the great news anxiety
is not the enemy we've been led to
believe I know this because I've walked
alongside countless folks over the last
two decades and I've struggled with this
too if you create a life of
intentionally living out the six daily
choices I've outlined in this book
you're gonna be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you you're
going to learn the choices you can make
day by day to create a more peaceful
joyful less chronically stressed
non-anxious life plus when you pre-order
my book I want to give you something to
help you today that's why you'll
instantly get my newest talk smoke fire
and freedom that I gave to several
thousand folks a few months ago where I
break down the misunderstandings and
myths we believe about anxiety how to
reclaim your freedom and how to build a
non-anxious life so pre-order building a
non his life today for just 20 bucks at
John deloney.com
all right hey as we wrap up today's show
um usually we have lyrics or like uh
something cool that happened I just want
to kind of run back through this Today's
Show because this is a hard one for me
um
and I know that this was a messy one and
none of these calls tied up at the end
and
unfortunately that's the world right
that's our life
um Jenna and Kelly do a great job of
picking calls that come in from all over
the world to say that that will we might
be able to wrap up but there's always
another layer and another layer another
layer
so just to run back through these calls
if you're married to somebody and they
leave you for a week for a business trip
and they refuse to call you
then they blame you for it
it's not your fault
if
you make a mistake in your marriage
after two years four years eight years
of what I would consider abusive
behavior and by the way if you tell
somebody you do this sex act that makes
you uncomfortable you don't want to do
or I'm going to kill myself or I'm Gonna
Leave You Forever you and the kids
that's manipulative and abusive
and then you do something you're not
proud of whatever that happens to be
you get a ticket in a school zone you
have a crush on a co-worker whatever the
thing happens to be
yes you are still lovable forever
you can you still have value
you got a lot to learn you got some you
got some some things I'm not going to do
again
but you're very much lovable
and if you found yourself being abusive
you got mental health challenges you've
been struggling you find yourself being
manipulative and you go oh my gosh I
don't want to be that person you have
value too
it's off that what you're doing stop and
go get help immediately
and almost every time separation is
important there
and if you got a kid who's being bullied
the first thing is I'm gonna get my kid
out of that environment if I can if it's
safe
and I know it's not possible for
everyone there's millions and millions
of people who can't just transfer
schools or just move schools or whatever
and it's also very important that we
create a generation of kid that knows
how to respond to bullies both online
and in person
that we cultivate friendships where we
friends will stand together and say not
that's not cool we're not we're not
having that anymore
but that means we are going to not just
do programs
but we're gonna as parents as neighbors
as friends we're going to teach our kids
hey when somebody says this this way you
say back
and I'm not saying you punch him in the
nose no that's that's the world we have
right now and it's not working
but there are some strategies that you
can learn to deal with bullying
there is a moment for staying on your
ground there is
and there's also a moment for him
getting my kid out of this mess
because over the last three years I've
had a joyful fun kid who's now depressed
and so anxious they can't breathe and
often that means there's stuff they're
not telling you because they're scared
of how you're going to respond
let's take care of our kids first let's
get them in a safe environment first and
then if we want to go try to change the
system great we'll change the system but
let's don't do it at their expense if at
all possible
and if you can't get your kid out and
teaching your kid is not working
raise alkan Hill
as much as you can go to whoever you can
call whoever you can continue to because
your kid's worth it
so sorry none of these these calls
wrapped up but I'm also not sorry
because this is our world man
do you know of kids getting bullied lean
in if you know of kids who are bullying
other kids lean in if you know of a
friend who is looking in the mirror and
thinks she's unlovable or he's unlovable
because of a thing they've done
get closer not further away
if you know of a buddy who's just took
off on his wife and he's like yeah I'll
have to see if the vibe's right
get in his business if he's your friend
all of us let's do better
[Music]
see you next time